meagan Markel has returned to her
California roots this time with her
family in tow matter et can confirm that
the Duke and Duchess of Sussex
officially said goodbye to Canada and
have relocated to Los Angeles I'm a
California girl I think all those hippy
dippy things have been in my DNA
so probably since the womb according to
our source it was always their plan to
eventually be based in California since
their work life will be focused in the
u.s. et has reached out to Megan and
Harry's reps for comment and I know I
haven't always doing it right but as far
as this goes there really was no other
option news of the move comes just days
before they officially stepped down as
senior Royals on March 31st
Megan Harry and their son Archie have
been living on Canada's Vancouver Island
since announcing their plans back in
January at the time the couple revealed
that they would split their time between
North America and the UK take notes I'm
not gonna repeat myself
of course Megan has ties to Canada after
spending years they're filming suits but
she was born and raised in LA and her
mom Doria Ragland also lives there Plus
let's not forget the speculation that
the 38 year old might reignite her
acting career we know she's already
landed a voice-over deal with Disney
the trailer for elephant dropped on
Thursday and it premieres on Disney Plus
April 3rd I never thought my life would
be that awesome
what did Megan Mark will say to you we
had a lovely conversation
first time I met her I've known him a
while he was the team's talked to me
about the fact that she was potentially
going to track a film only time will
tell what the Sussex is will do next
like everyone else they're currently
trying to protect their family amid the
corona virus pandemic a source told ET
on Wednesday that the couple has been
practicing safe behaviors to help
flatten the curve and slow the spread of
the virus adding that Megan has been
video chatting with her friends and has
even swapped recipes with some of them
to make it home typical noisy night just
roasting chicken and meanwhile Harry's
been making moves - earlier this month
he teamed up with Bon Jovi and the
Invictus games choir at Abbey Road
Studios to rerecord the singer's
military-inspired song unbroken and even
though the games have been postponed
until 2021 the rocker shared the new
rendition of his hit on Thursday
I was born
stay true
[Music]
you